the biggest question with scholar of the
first sin is who is it for because
they're not just porting the game to
next-gen they're actually adding
elements that might make you want to
play again they're incentivizing another
playthrough for old players and
enhancing the experience for new ones
and ultimately that is a good thing but
it's kind of forced you into this
awkward position where you have to ask
yourself the question is it worth it for
me to play through this game again and
everybody's going to have a different
answer for that some people might just
download the free patch On February 5th
and some people might repurchase the
entire game for their more powerful
systems in April both of these versions
will have different features so if you
want a list of those then you should
definitely check out the description
because it can get pretty confusing but
most of you are interested in the
next-gen version that offers everything
the new enemy placements the new enemies
the different law everything and that's
what I got to play this week I made the
trip down to San Francisco where I got
to play the full game and I got to learn
about what exactly was new so I hope I
can help you guys decide whether you'd
want to play another playthrough or
whether you'd like to make another
purchase so there are going to be three
major things that might entice you to
play there's improved enemy placements
improved graphics and better
storytelling so let's start with enemy
placements and what I got to see the
first thing everybody at the event
noticed was this ogre he wasn't there
before
you have to sneak past him and it
introduces a stealth element centered
around an enemy new players definitely
should have realized is difficult at
this point further up in a clearing up
the ladder there's almost three times as
many hollows lying in wait for you and
getting through this section is like
going through a minefield trying to only
aggro one enemy at a time and trying not
to get overwhelmed in the next section
there's now an archer shooting at you
while you fight other enemies in melee
so these areas and the enemies within
them are designed way better than they
were previously and as you play through
the entire game you realize that most
sections that were lacking before have
improvements like these now
you'll see a bunch of them in the
footage being shown I'm sure some are
better because the enemies are in
different places and some flat-out have
different enemies that just make more
sense in those locations expect some
hate nights actually in hade and more
desert Sorceress's in harvest valley you
know that kind of thing since this game
is running on better hardware the AI is
better two enemies will chase you
practically forever now from what I
could tell
so they'll catch you if you try to run
through an area and you also notice
enemies patrolling now you know moving
around in the environment which forces
you to learn their patterns and
sometimes can make an area feel a bit
more real and a bit more lived-in if
that makes sense so the elements of the
better AI like having enemies follow you
further was explained to me as a result
of having better hardware and speaking
of better hardware let's talk about the
graphics and the lighting in this build
so you should have got a pretty good
feel of what it looks like simply put
the game feels like you're playing on PC
it's 60 FPS it's got sharper textures
and that's all great but it's not quite
as pretty as the demo was which I know a
lot of you were hoping for me included
but it is better than the console and
the PC versions from what I can tell and
I am really happy to announce that one
feature of the demo has made it through
to the next-gen versions of the game the
dark areas you first notice this in the
basement that you can unlock after the
last giant so everything immediately
becomes pitch black just like it did in
the demo and you finally get to make
that decision should I use a torch in my
off hand and see more or should I use a
shield and defend against the things
coming at me in the darkness so I'm sure
it's no coincidence that all of the
enemies in the dark area have changed so
you won't know what's in there and you
won't know what's coming at you but the
thing is the environments haven't
changed so for an experienced player who
knows how to navigate these areas you
probably won't spend very long in the
dark areas because you'll just dash
right through and that's a bit of a -
but for new players this is awesome and
I'm really
be for them to be honest it wasn't dark
in as many areas as I hoped it would be
but at least they've upped the contrast
so you can't just go through dark areas
with your brightness settings turned up
anymore and it's cool to have this
implemented but like I said better for
new players not as great for experienced
players so the world hasn't changed but
there are more significant encounters
and I imagine for a new player the
entire game is going to be a much more
memorable experience but for an old
player an experienced player coming back
the most they're probably going to get
out of you is a that's new kind of
feeling and that's what I got when I was
going through the game isn't a
completely revolutionised experience so
you shouldn't buy it or play it
expecting that one of the biggest things
that will change your experience though
is the placement of weapons I found the
grand Lance shortly after the last giant
and I used it all the way until the
demon of song so that was a refreshing
character change for me usually I pick
up a weapon like the S stock or the
great sword and I pretty much go through
most of the game with that but since all
the weapons are switched around it means
that you'll be crafting entirely
different characters to tackle a
slightly different experience so that's
pretty cool but overall if you liked
Dark Souls 2 then you'll like it even
more but if you don't like Dark Souls 2
because the level design is lacking or
because you didn't like the enemies or
the bosses then nothing scholar of the
first sin will do can fix that the world
is the same the flow of the game is the
same the enemy designs are the same and
for you the only thing that might be
interesting is the story item
descriptions have changed in a big way
pretty much everyone I read had an extra
paragraph added to it which you'll be
able to see when the patch drops On
February 5th so you can expect a lot of
videos on this stuff and even if you
don't play you'll be able to see that
and experience that so make sure you're
subscribed for that but mostly though I
expect the major story significance to
come towards the end of the game
so overall everyone's going to be in a
different camp with scholar of the first
sin
and there are a lot of options available
to you I'd really love if you could tell
me what you plan on doing are you going
to download the patch and just meet the
scholar of the first sin or will you
wait until April and play through with
updated graphics and updated enemy
behaviors and enemy placements or will
you do neither of those things and are
you interested in watching my videos on
the scholar of the first sin so there's
a straw poll down below and a comment
section for you all to vote in so I can
try to figure out how many of you are
actually interested in this and it's
also worth noting that I'm really
confident that PC players will be
getting a discount when repurchasing the
game but you really should definitely
wait for an official statement on that
so thanks for watching guys I'll be
bringing you some scholar of the first
sin and also some blood-borne stuff as
soon as I get back home so there's a lot
of stuff to cover in the next few months
and I'll talk to you next time Cheers